congratulations on the finale of season
four now finally being out i'm sure it's
probably a little bit of a relief
to be able to talk about everything
yes it is and thank you
um it's been really fascinating watching
your journey this season because we
discovered that not only are you only
playing one character but you're
technically playing three characters in
one i think that's that's a little more
accurate to say um
how soon after you were cast did you
find out who you were really playing
uh good question i so the the process
was um was an interesting one in terms
of being cast so i'm sure you've read or
might have heard you know i i had two
sets of sides from other projects that
was given to me for the first
tape and then one set of sides dummy
sites um from the show
and
then i
made a mood board and then i went to go
meet matt and ross uh and have a
conversation with them and it was at
that point
that they kind of told me everything and
it was at that point that i sort of was
basically given the opportunity to to
work with them
um
so
it was very very early on i knew
i knew
pretty much everything bar a couple of
things that we find out in this uh in in
this uh
in this
volume um
so
yes it was it was quite soon um and i
had kind of pieced together as well you
know given the sites that i was given
from primal fear
that particularly for
henry
he was presenting
he was
he was
manipulating l but also having to act in
a certain way in order to survive his
environment
and then when she uh when she meets
his
when she kind of comes in at the end of
episode seven and meets his
true feelings
um
you know that's when that's when
everything had kind of dropped um so
i knew i knew pretty soon is the answer
was
your role as vechna was that something
that was kind of withheld from the rest
of the cast for a certain point like was
there a period where only very few
people knew who was actually in the suit
or
was that something that everybody kind
of knew up front
everybody
sort of knew it um
they
at the read through in in march of 2020
before everything went mad
um
we uh
we um
i was reading the vector lines and
obviously reading a bit of um a bit of
henry as well and and actually
it was more of the reveal that henry
and
wechner and one were all the same person
that people didn't really know
um
we didn't even get up to i believe in
the read through episode seven so i
think we actually just i think we just
had gotten to six i might be wrong there
um but yeah i i think that was the
biggest reveal for everyone but vetner
people knew pretty soon pretty early on
just because there was so much work
involved in having to make everything
beforehand
i mean speaking of how much work went
into this character the prosthetics are
incredible
but they also look very all-encompassing
um
so
from the position of someone who has to
not only wear all that but act through
all of that what are some of the ways
that you kind of felt like you had to
adjust your performance to account for
all that affects makeup
um
first of all like physically i started
imagining and thinking about the length
of particularly the left hand
um
how i would move that how i would hold
myself
given all the things i believe and the
strength and the power that he has
um
and then on a sort of more like
energetic and spiritual level came this
forcing
energy and aura from my skin through the
prosthetic piece so that the prosthetic
piece itself became the skin that makes
sense
um and just
owning the space that i was in
particularly the mindless um
where
everything is much larger and the set
was so big
that i needed to even in a wide shot
uh it needed to feel
like i was dominating that space
um so that was an interesting thing
particularly sort of in meditation and
in just in stillness
as well trying to just
exude that a little bit more did you
have a vector playlist or any other like
character like songs or anything that
you would listen to to kind of get into
that headspace
yeah all the time i listened to sono
revenge carpathian forest
uh a bit of the cure
um
norma gene
um
mayhem
so a lot of kind of darker black metal
um
and bursum i mean you know the list is
kind of endless
um
so yeah i'd always have that on and and
i i've said this a few times but
low frequency sound for me is something
that really grounds me so i'd also
listen to a lot of low frequency low
frequency sounds and um yeah so i do i
do have a playlist and even now if i
need to
it would it just made me feel powerful
in this in an interesting way it was it
was strange it was old music has that
ability we definitely get the final
confrontation with vecna at the end at
the finale but there is a sense that
business is not left unfinished so does
this mean we can safely say that we will
see you again in season five
you can safely say whatever you like
my lips my lips are very sealed very
very much sealed in terms of season five
i'll uh
matt and ross i'm sure have have plans
and designs so um
we'll leave it up to we'll leave it up
to our captains to uh to tell everyone
what they are thinking
fair enough all right well on that note
i am all out of time but thank you so
much for taking the time out of your day
to sit and chat with me about this show
it has been
so much fun to see you get to be bad on
stranger things this season and i hope
we get to see more you're very kind
thank you so much carly i really
appreciate your time today and thank you
for um thank you for a lovely interview
appreciate it thank you all right take
care